CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell says leaving
the climate Accord is the worst decision
the president has made I spoke with the
former CI acting director for my PBS
program and when I think about the world
and I think about the the threats to the
preservation of the nation there were
only three that I can see the first is a
nuclear war with Russia the second is a
it is a naturally-occurring
or man-made biological agent that kills
a significant percentage of the
population and the third is climate
change
climate change is that serious over the
long term if this goes through right and
the next president doesn't change it
this this decision is going to make the
climate worse worse and and therefore
have national security implications from
that very significant perspective CBS
News chief Washington correspondent and
Face the Nation anchor John Dickerson
joins us now from Washington John good
morning morning Charlie so with all this
opposition from around the globe and
here what does the president gain well
what he gains is is the support of those
who are his most ardent supporters and
there is so much in this deal and when
you look at the way he talked about it
that was pitched to those people who
support him and who see this kind of a
deal and think about the way the
president phrased it is the rest of the
world is laughing at America that this
was something cooked up by elites and
globalists to kind of trick the
Americans into weakening its own economy
for some kind of fuzzy agreement that
put America at a disadvantage and so
what he he gains is the affection and
and the applause of his base that sent
him to Washington but people say he
already had that and he's been they've
been through him thick and thin and what
is done is isolated America from the
rest of the world but he doesn't mind
isolating America from the rest of the
world and the and the
harsh comments from Europe are just fine
with the president who just doesn't
think that America should do things that
are not in its interest just because
some foreign capitals in Europe think
it's a bad idea and yes he's got a very
strong base but his view of politics is
essentially that his base is what he
needs to tend and keep keep paying
attention to when when I was with him in
Harrisburg a few weeks ago at a rally
when he talked about the Paris Accords
in these terms in other words that these
are this is something cooked up by the
globalists there were roars when he
spoke in opposition to it and that is a
roar that he keeps always in the back of
his head likes to keep feeding it and
would have diminished it if he had
bought into this globalist agreement
here what does this say about the
influence of the presidents top advisors
well I think at the and we've also got
to think about the political context
here next week the president may be in a
very big fight as James Comey testifies
what the president has done is in the
Rose Garden stood up for what for the
nationalist views the American first
views that Steve Bannon supports that
Scott Pruett his EPA Administrator
supports this is the kind of core P part
of the Trump worldview that one out here
that's always very close to his heart
it's something he talks about a lot how
much his base still loves him how much
his base takes energy from him being
attacked by elites that is always
something he's interested in but in the
current political context him coming
forward and being able to talk about
these core ideas is not bad when he's
facing some political pressure from
other quarters John thanks